- Republican Congressman
Mo Brooks hoists himself
on his own petard by screwing himself
out of getting a defense
from the government.
You might recall that Eric
Swalwell filed a lawsuit
against some of the people
he believes are responsible
for the January 6th insurrection.
Congressman Mo Brooks tried
to get out of the suit
by invoking the Westfall Act,
which basically says you can't
sue a government official
for acts that occurred
during the course and scope
of their governmental duties.
And if the Westfall Act
applies, this is complicated,
but effectively, the
official just gets dismissed
from the suit.
Now, Mo Brooks claimed that
when he was making his speech
on January 6th, this was
in the course and scope
of his duties as a Congressman.
But in trying to defeat the lawsuit itself
and invoke this privilege, he said
that he was basically making
political campaign speeches,
and there are all kinds of regulations
that say a sitting congressperson
cannot make campaign speeches
in the course and scope
of their duties as an elected official.
So by Mo Brooks's own sworn testimony,
the Westfall Act doesn't apply,
and the DOJ is not going to defend him.
So we will definitely be
seeing Mo Brooks in court.